in my last video on parasite I talked
about the film's visual architecture
focusing on production design and the
spatial layout of the world I touched a
bit on house in monography was used to
help create that structure but there are
many other ways that cinematography
plays a significant role in shaping the
story so in this video let's take a
broader look at parasite cinematography
the use of camera movement and
composition to help pace the film keep
us engaged and illustrate its themes
this video is sponsored by audible
in the first half of the film as the Kim
family moves deeper and deeper into
their con the camera consistently slowly
pushes forward almost barely perceptible
in many of these shots but easily
noticeable if I speed it up this slow
creep forward gives each of these
moments a foreboding sense of
progression towards something
[Music]
once the Kim's achieve their goal and
have status in the house the camera
stops moving forward movement forward
and backward becomes much more static
and is only occasionally used through
the rest of the film to andthis eyes
specific moments under I as the Khan
develops bong joon-ho uses visual cues
to connect similar moments in the film a
slow pan marks the escalation of the con
in both of these scenes this slow pan
was used at the beginning of the film
when men pitches the idea of conning the
parks to ki woo
Raja yoga given each one kun da da watan
112 a bonus una botella room for all we
come when Fela Kuti Shiva English see
you got your pendant OHS I gotta - Kabir
I got you - among the things particular
with off a similar pan is used again
when Mr Kim begins pitching his wife as
a housekeeper - mr. Park
parasite only has about 960 shots a bit
below the average of 1,250 but the
pacing of the film actually feels quite
quick in your average Hollywood film you
might see this scene progress like this
cutting between angles but bong often
uses longer takes without cutting these
takes rarely feel very long because they
aren't static bong uses developing
composition and camera work to
incorporate wide medium and close-up
shots into a single take bongs
immaculate storyboarding and shot
planning allows him to use camera
movement and blocking in concert to help
develop scenes in this scene mr. parks
movement towards the trashcan is what
motivates the horizontal camera
but that movement continues and is what
ends up revealing to the audience a new
element of the scene in the film more
free-flowing Steadicam shots are used
within the big house to emphasize the
size of the space and the freedom in the
rich family's lifestyle in the Kim's
house shots are often more locked down
and simple but as the Kim's start to see
the benefit of their new jobs in their
lives the camera becomes freer and more
complex in its movement the film's
static tripod shots precise pans steady
dolly shots and flowing Steadicam
tracking shots are exchanged for
handheld shots at its climax though
these shots are handheld and slightly
more unsteady they're no less precisely
composed often including multiple
careful compositions in a single take by
reserving handheld for these moments
long maximizes its effect in contrast to
the steadier cinematography of the rest
of the film
parasites composition uses the set to
help reinforce one of its themes Thunder
a concern has moved in kidney
she runs off with a Hollywood Hollywood
film a faithfully that attends kill made
our little movie a stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
some bunch of remodeling done is no
longer things like local children's
welfare and Control in the beauty that
ends in a Philips game shakers
[Music]
[Applause]
none of these techniques were
specifically pioneered by bong joon-ho
and parasite isn't even the first time
he's used most of them the bong displays
a mastery and ease with the camera and
bringing his vision to the screen that's
admirably there's clear intention behind
every shot but wonderfully these things
don't draw attention to themselves bongs
long takes or well choreographed
tracking shots aren't there for show but
because they serve each moment of the
story best thanks to audible for
sponsoring this video was a membership
you'll get one credit for an audiobook
each month and two originals you can
spend your credit on any audiobook
regardless of price get your first
credit for free with your 30 day free
trial when you go to audible.com slash
Thomas flight one of your options for
spending that credit is David Lynch's
audiobook catching the big fish it's
right by Lynch himself and it gives us
an inside look into his creative process
if you don't like an audiobook you can
exchange it for another one I like
knowing that I can get a different
audiobook if I change my mind because it
makes me a lot more adventurous with the
audiobooks I choose you can start
listening today with a 30-day audible
trial choose one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free
there's a audible.com slash Thomas
flight or text
Thomas flight - 500 500
thank you so much for watching special
thank you to my patreon supporters each
month I put out a podcast for my patrons
I go behind-the-scenes on why I make
certain videos talk more about the films
I'm discussing in my essays and just
give a general overview of the things
that I'm watching
[Music]